you'll see that your circle intersects
the axes at four spots right one on the
positive wire one of the negative wire
one of the positive x one of the
negative x okay we're going to label
each of those as one if it's on the
positive side or negative one input on
the negative sides we've got one one
negative one negative one and there's
the center at the origin 0 0 okay now
this is a circle Center at the origin
it's a special circle because since it
goes 1 1 negative 1 negative 1 what is
the size what is the radius of this
circle it's exactly 1 right because
we're on the Cartesian plane is not
centimeters or meters we just call them
units right so it's one unit that's the
radius of this thing since it's one unit
we call this guy the unit circle it's a
circle with a radius of one unit ok now
this bad boy is going to give us a
better definition for sine and a few
other things as you'll see it in a
second as well we're going to pop onto
here one of the radii okay I said the
radius is 1 unit okay so let's just
stick one of the radii over yeah so you
can see the Cartesian plane is broken up
into four sections because there are
four of them we call them quadrants
right what we've got over here where
both of their values are the x value is
positive and the y value positive we
call this guy the first quadrant so the
first quadrant I put a radius in there
okay and I'm going to show that measures
out a little angle here coming up from
the x-axis up to the radius subjoin
I'm just going to call that angle theta
all right you guys have seen we tend to
use theta as our label fraggles a lot so
what are they have formed in here in
this circle is one of these right angle
triangle
you see I've got the angle that I'm
interested in everything bottom left so
I'm a right angle triangle happening
here I'm going to draw our line
vertically down to the axis and to
complete the triangle I'm going to draw
along the x-axis until I get my 90
degrees in there okay now the reason I
draw this is I'm trying to draw a bridge
right the tree dimension ratios they
start in right angle triangles that's
where they begin okay so I've got this
right angle triangle in here and I'm
gonna show us how to extend past where
right angle triangles can go so in this
triangle remember radius of one so the
hypotenuse of this triangle is one do
you agree with that and he's just the
radius so it's 1 now if I have a point
up here wait I'm just going to label it
painful point okay I'm interested in
where this point actually resides
somewhere on this circle okay so if you
have a look and don't don't draw this
yet you've sort of already been a
triangle sense enough for me okay if I
want to know the x-coordinate of this
point that's this distance here isn't it
right
this distance is the x-coordinate if it
was like 0.5 over that distance then the
corner will be 0.5 something right and
in the same way this vertical distance
is the y-coordinate
that's what Y means vertical okay so
therefore I'm interested in what each of
these sides are I'm gonna call this one
X and this one why because I'm not
horizontal and I've got vertical okay
now remember that this is one tell me in
this triangle will start with sign since
that's why we're trying to redefine
what's sine theta in this triangle
it's it's officer on hypotenuse isn't it
it's Y over 1 which is just why do you
agree with that right now while we're at
it since you've got Y there you can see
I can make a similar kind of argument to
get the length of X right X is the
adjacent if I compare to the hypotenuse
which I rubbed it off which ratio is
adjacent and hypotenuse it's cause it's
a cosine so I could say cos theta is
adjacent on hypotenuse do you see that x
over 1 which of course is just X okay so
now I'm going to bring that over to our
diagram here right
if this horizontal distance here is
close phenome and this vertical distance
here is sine theta the lose of the
coordinates of P cos theta sine theta
that's where P is right because when you
ask for coordinates if I say don't draw
this if I say all right he is 3 and
here's for you would say oh I know what
the coordinates of this thing are right
this distance is 4 1 2 3 4 so that's the
x coordinate and then you go up 1 2 3
and that's the y coordinate okay so I
have gone horizontally this distance so
that's what my x coordinate is and I
brought vertically this distance so
that's what my Y coordinates
okay now have a think about this right
and think about that graph that you drew
about five minutes ago right if the x
coordinate is cos and the y coordinate
is so think about his theta
think about what would happen if I made
feeder 0 you remember that's that not
triangle right it's like he's the bottom
and then he's the other side because in
between those is zero degrees right
if feeder came down to
here's where my inverted commas triangle
would be right it would be going down to
here on the circle whatever coordinates
of that little spot on the axis think
about it hmm now I've got a cross one I
do my X's and mi Y's goods alphabetical
right so I'm gonna go one unit across
how far by going up zero I haven't gone
up right I'm on the answers is zero okay
which is why you see the sign is that y
coordinate there it is right we were
looking at the graph and we were
guessing that sine of zero right there
in the corner is zero it is that's why
you can continue the argument remember I
tried to make that right angry triangle
with two right angles in it okay well I
couldn't put a right angle here at theta
where would it be if I made this
training it would go all the way up to
here right do you see that there's my
right angle in there what are the
coordinates at that point at the top
they're not going to be 1 0 either
they're going to be 0 and then 1 so this
is 4 theta that's 90 degrees it's going
all the way up from one access to the
other and that there is sine of 90
degrees it's the y-coordinate okay so we
are totally redefining the way we speak
your sign there's no ratios anymore what
not obviously right I'm not talking
about this over this or this over this
I'm talking about
what's that coordinate over there okay
so let's write this write a new
definition for sine is
I keep on talking about the fact that
it's this Y value right it's this guy
over here which might be zero or one or
anything in between okay a new
definition for sine is the y coordinate
on the unit circle formed by a radius
now I'm going to write a long phrase
here and then I'm going to explain it on
the board because so much easier to see
in the picture versus verbally but I
want you to have the verbal definition
okay there's a long phrase let me read
the whole thing and then we'll look at
the picture in your see a new definition
for sign I would argue a better
definition is it's the y-coordinate
whatever this number is right on the
unit circle there's my circle formed by
a radius there is there's that radius
with angle theta measured from a
particular spot right
I don't just measure from anywhere it's
a little bit tricky because different
angles if you think back to bearings
different angles measure from different
locations right this one's measuring
from really with me the positive x-axis
see using the x-axis Novocain right and
there's the positive side this one's in
the negative side right I've got
negative one two three four five going
over here right so I got positive there
that's where I'm from
now you don't need to rewrite it all
over again but you can see this new
definition for sign gives me a
corresponding definition for cosine
right I'll write exactly the same thing
out and I would change one thing right
cosine is this guy over here right it's
not the y-coordinate it's the
x-coordinate yeah so a new definition
for cosine is the x-coordinate on the
unit circle formed by etc etc etc okay
so these two are linked together now in
a new way now this is really powerful